thank you
[Music]
a man in Hong Kong
lost control
of his hydrogen balloon which he was
using to harvest pine nuts
so he's like floating up to get the pine
nuts I get a hot air balloon like in a
in a bunch of hydrogen balloons okay and
then you [ __ ] lost control and he
kept going to space he kept going up
going up and up and up and up and up
that's stupid he ends up in the upper
atmosphere
team Team Rocket blasting off again
stupid he just becomes a glimmer he
becomes lucky Chan one yeah his buddy
who's working on the pine nuts with him
he notices they're losing control and he
[ __ ] jumps off and lands to safety
and then this cat is like well maybe I
can bring it in still and then he just
gets taken all the way up in the [ __ ]
utter upper Stratosphere oh my God
he went [ __ ] all the way up does he
use that to pick peaches or something
kindness
I was taking I was putting away this
bullet wound kit I don't know exactly
right yeah the balloon was flying did it
go
you know how like when a balloon pops
and it goes oh
it went straight up because the hydrogen
blew in it's not a birthday balloon
it's very un theatrical rise yeah that's
boring so but but it you said that it
the like air was coming out when it was
going up or it was just no it was it was
it couldn't pop one he just lost control
he lost control so it just kept going oh
it's supposed to weigh them down like
somewhat yeah well the dude jumping out
probably didn't help they just shot him
up
went 50 feet up immediately oh [ __ ] good
luck he killed him dude and he
disappeared like no one appeared in the
upper Stratosphere well what goes up
must come down so so he did uh two days
later he lands in a [ __ ] Forest 300
miles away
[Music]
the the balloon slowly landed slowly it
slowly lost
um yeah slowly lost mass and returned to
the earth
I think he did he's like that guy
yeah it must be super freezing and his
ears must hurt I'm glad
it's good he landed on land and it
wasn't like in like The Ocean song well
he laid in the middle of a [ __ ]
Forest but at least he died though right
he's alive it's like Jackie Chan yeah
he's live because
Rescuers his colleague like um obviously
[ __ ] him a little bit because he
jumped off and they need to weigh that
thing down but his call he told
everybody like what happened and they
actually were able to trace his mobile
phone to where he was which is how they
know he was an upper [ __ ]
stratosphere
so yeah they said he was like he said I
find my iPhone and he's like he's here
like the dot is there but they don't
know that he's up I know they're at the
spot they're like bro he's not here
they're at Chinese Costco like it says
right here and it's like on top of them
but the scariest thing for Rescuers was
they had to try to access his cell phone
information without having him use his
phone which they had him put in airplane
mode as not to interfere with the
eclipse oh I can really [ __ ] with it can
really really really seriously mode
really [ __ ] with hydrogen balloons
you got to really take that airplane
mode seriously create a dicey situation
for The Rescuers because that's what
caused the balloons to flare up if he
turns it on that could be a real problem
5G is not meant to be a combo with this
boy was low-key trying to murder him and
he did he thought he got away with it
and he comes back down he's like hey man
I was pulling the right
how was it up there yeah like you must
have been hungry hi I got all the pine
nuts in my backpack oh man oh no I had a
little pouch in my in my fanny pack it's
like a dumb and dumber moment so this is
a great way to market the surveillance
Big Brother State you know so it's like
hey you want privacy but if you have
privacy there's no way we could have
triangulated your location because you
we wouldn't have known where you were
but now we could save you because you
know China wow how long was up there two
days and he's a dead body in the forest
no He's Alive they found him because he
traced his cell phone signal but I just
want to know how they survive like what
like what did he say how it felt up
there it's cold as [ __ ] right it was no
He's Alive God damn it okay he said I
almost gave up thanks to Rescuers
otherwise I wouldn't be alive because he
landed in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
right so so it's not like he thought he
was gonna land and he was gonna be Gucci
right he thought he's like God damn I'm
about to suffer even more they were just
waiting for that balloon to go go down
to like ah yeah they had him they had
his back yeah so then he said he was
cold he was hungry He was largely
unharmed he only had minor injuries to
his waist where he was tied to the
tether to the balloon he um but the use
this use using these balloons to harvest
pine nuts is pretty common but also
becoming common is incidents involving
guys who are picking with these balloons
who get carried away yeah some [ __ ]
Tom and Jerry [ __ ] when they get carried
away with him is there a picture of the
balloon wait said you said Tethered to
the balloon that means he's not in a
basket he's just [ __ ] has a harness
he's he was somehow Tyler to balloon
they don't say as usual it doesn't say
exactly because if it's like a personal
pen Pizza [ __ ] balloon it's probably
not like a a nice looking basket why not
and at what point did he just like rest
and like chill like all right I'm just
gonna be up here yeah yeah
like connected to a balloon probably
looks like a [ __ ] beach chair that he
like tied to a balloon honestly like
like what are you talking about it's
just panties
so it looks like this
so it looks like this a little one look
at that just looking like a giant condom
blown up oh so there's a little basket
oh okay wow he was trying to debunk
Steve's article with information great
yeah with the truth okay A little
personal hot air balloon up in the
stratosphere like that's [ __ ] crazy
man do you guys know what a pine nut is
yeah you make a pesto with it all right
oh yeah can you please Google it's like
a little white ones it's like this big
you know what a beetle mushrooms
yeah but it's really bad for you yeah
you make pesto with that
every now and then I'm a Clapper Steve
this is gonna get a streamy dude
I don't think that we compete with
ourselves for the streaming they
rejected our application for would you
[ __ ] your mom or your dad really they
rejected it they were so thirsty I know
they rejected her out of hand it was so
promising that video how do you reject
the classic I thought that was the one
why would they I mean we're like we've
been on YouTube for so long they don't
[ __ ] it's weird we're getting our
respect hey we're gonna respect no it's
not them it's us guys we gotta redefine
ourselves and pine nuts a good start
we're trying we're trying man we're God
damn we're trying Mobility yeah so um in
2019 two men were picking pine cones in
China's Chiang Bai mountains they lost
control of their balloon drifted six
miles before landing safely and my
favorite part being arrested for
breaking Aviation
[Laughter]
can you imagine this [ __ ]
any kind of rescue that ends with click
is so [ __ ] hilarious job is picking
pine cones yeah what is the use of a
pint I don't know you get carried away
and you're like Yeah well my life sucks
already well I guess what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen next oh God and like
you're arrested for violating laws you
pieces of [ __ ]
be more responsible you don't have a
vertical passport and you know those
guys doing the pine cone [ __ ] they
probably have to turn upside down and
get shaken out before they leave because
you say you better not be taking Paco's
home
they'll stay with us it's for all the
Chinese uh summer camps
[Music]
foreign
[Music]